hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to notes of obsession now
this indie horror game came out very
recently and it's supposedly getting
incredible reviews because it's so like
actually good-looking like ridiculously
ridiculously good-looking and that's not
everything to a horror game but this is
really interesting about it and wow that
is an incredible amount of detail to put
in a single game and the first thing I
actually noticed is I can see the
patterns on the wall but anyway that's
not all that makes up a horror game so
let's find out what there is to this one
oh hey is that my son yeah not looking
so good there that's a while again hello
is this my house why was I falling
asleep on the couch oh hello [ __ ] you
Jesus don't do that to me who has a
sliding door like that anyway also who
did that probably worrisome is perfectly
normal to have figurines of ourselves in
our own house I'm assuming I'm the wife
because it sounded like a feminine
voices I was getting up so that seems
like a possible murder weapon that I'm
probably gonna be using later on but who
knows
ah yes bad the thing that I don't
actually fall asleep on ah yes rain the
perfect mood for a murderous story of
horror and death ah yes empty house with
no loved ones in a troubled past so like
most games I don't know a lot going into
it and like most horror games is
probably gonna have a good number of
jump scares so be on the lookout it's
gonna be wild oh wait a minute why
couldn't I go in the main door someone
in here huh something better not be in
here hi are you doing
that's comforting I love the music ah
yes it's gonna be good always delightful
when you're walking down the hallway by
yourself towards some creepy-ass music
oh talk off that [ __ ] don't do that
that was not okay you are a son of a
[ __ ]
hello Oh No
empty kid's bed with the name the
Claddagh I don't know this is made by
Swedish game design students I think
about 17 of them okay well that doesn't
look too ominous by itself but I imagine
it's gonna cause problems for me high
demonic symbol that burned itself into
my wall that's perfectly normal
talk of the right mouse button to close
and open the music box oh right well the
left mouse button activate ah oh cool
what did that do what horrible
monstrosity do
okay-y
oh you have no legs well how do you
ladies who's over there I'm gonna I'm
gonna Jack slap the [ __ ] out of you oh
hey oh Fant ah oh well so it's gonna be
like that huh it's gonna be like that
let's see if there's any other secrets
around here you know being on Bing bong
Bing bong I am going to [ __ ] my pants oh
boy here we go
yes what freaka dick how the [ __ ] did I
get in here now don't put it away put it
up put it up and turn it on No oh what
the [ __ ]
okay how did I get in there well that
doesn't make any goddamn sense what the
hell is this [ __ ] don't put it away stop
putting it away I keep hitting the wrong
button
come on
okay so I got to interact with these
symbols oh oh oh ah there we go
hello on the TV that's a guy didn't need
a brand new TV ah I wasn't even looking
you gotta jump scare me when I'm paying
attention not what I'm doing anything
else come on
okay oh god damn it is gonna be like PT
oh this so like PT Oh God Oh cranky
cranky - Yankee Yankee yeah Oh me no
likey that okay all right
are you okay oh okay
we went through the door at the same
time that prophet saw occupied
I'm busy in here [ __ ] me
knock him out anybody anybody can i
crank this yank why oh the elephants
Oh what did you do Oh what did you do
why do I need to crouch holy [ __ ] do I
have to crouch uh-huh is there something
over here
Oh the painting was knocked over okay
bye okay alrighty then
is anybody over here does anybody need
to get music Pookie really my only
weapon to my own madness is there
something over here that doesn't seem to
seem to be anything over here
so what was the point oh there I see I
see you got ya alrighty then that was
one there's three in here yeah
where ah there I got you I see you who
in there really why I don't know why
there's gotta be another one around here
somewhere
hey buddy ah friend can you tell me
where the last symbol is either I'm a
big dum-dum can't figure this out or
it's somewhere hidden I don't know which
is worse
ah there you are on the beanbag I should
have known right by elephant but okay
carry on
ah [ __ ] we're back again why are we back
oh jeez give me that
like I'm being chased by an Allegiant
monster use exotic reserves evident by
[ __ ]
I just got to go through tour I guess
all right bye okay I thought there was
gonna be something else that was gonna
pop ha ha ha woo guess oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you
come on now why you gotta be dick a tree
okay oh no oh no oh no we're reliving
the nightmare over and over and over
oh [ __ ] why are we have it here huh why
we have here huh we're not done yet
apparently let me collect all the
symbols there's gonna be a bit more of a
[ __ ] to find cuz there's so many of ya
okay so that's why do I need to unlock
the knife why is that a thing I see you
over there I'm coming to get you you
simple [ __ ] I got you we thought you
could hide from me the intruders know so
I gotta find all these sacks of crap and
I got to imagine that the probably one
in each room or something to that effect
if not who can't hide from me are you
what the [ __ ] was that
oh [ __ ] I need to hide wring out I
shouldn't be yelling oh I didn't know
that you were actually Oh God oh oh oh
huh okay ah what are you doing
[ __ ] dude oh [ __ ]
can I close the door can I turn on my
music box probably did not a good idea
but I'm gonna do it anyway
alright anything in here I probably
shouldn't be here oh I should be running
away very fastly is that thing still
even in here right not right
that's what I tell myself oh hello got
you I saw you you got it I don't know
who that is sound good is the place
getting more decrepit doors edges me
probably more okay bye bye bye thank you
what the [ __ ] who's that what [ __ ] was
that want to tell me what that was I
thought this was starting to be a pretty
decent Devore game then you want to pull
that [ __ ] with me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
I'm going upstairs [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] you
haha okay got one in here
ah oh that's not a good sound
am I gonna be cornered up here that's
like lost me all [ __ ] you
well lady not go as I planned
that was bad [ __ ] okay
I see it's still giving me all the
credit for all my dastardly deeds but
hopefully oh well I'm gonna close that
we don't need that you don't need to
bring silly things such as music boxes
[ __ ] off saw you there oh she did he see
me
we they're not seen me seem to me Oh
yeah dude got you guess-who
exit fix it oh I thought that's a deck
[ __ ] off
with you and that thing that you do okay
doesn't look like there's one in here
I'm gonna try to venture out again just
missing one more thing I'm pretty sure
okay okay okay okay oh oh god damn it
I've been looking all over them I've
been looking all over the home for that
oh that don't sound good why the
laughing why do you need laughing me
alright okay then
well let's pick up the knife cuz nothing
good could come out of this I mean I
could kill a monster with it Hey oh man
I gun for that son of a [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh wow
oh no oh no oh no oh no why is the blood
covering the portrait of the son
that's not a good sign oh okay that's
gonna be the end of it then oh great oh
boy okay well so that is notes of
obsession this was really well made I
gotta commend the makers of this game
this is absolutely incredible there was
a big team behind this animation was of
professional quality the environments
were delightfully like filled and
fleshed out it looked like a lived-in
house they had wonderful mechanics with
the looping though was reminiscent of
Petey and then they came out of it into
like a haunting around the house type of
deal so good use of a small location so
that's what I have to say about the game
thank you to the developers for making
it and thank you everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh God